nossa muita gente ver se é então talvez
seja o palestrante mais o novo do ted de
todos os tedx em mas eu acho que essa
mensagem vai mais para os pais
acho que devem ter alguns pais aqui
nossa platéia e porque nervoso me
desculpe eu posso ter só 13 anos mas
pelo pouco que eu vivi até agora eu
aprendi algumas coisas sobre uma coisa
chamada sistema
estou pensando por que a gente tem que
seguir sempre um certo padrão de beleza
um certo padrão de vida um certo padrão
de ser como por exemplo fazer um jardim
de infância
o fundamental o ensino médio e para uma
faculdade e ter um emprego de sucesso é
isso
basicamente os nossos pais fazem alguns
ou muitos não sei por que eu ainda não
sou é se espelhar
por exemplo meu pai
hoje ele gostaria que eu fosse
farmacêutico médico
eu falei não há pai não vocês eu vou ser
um grande chef de cozinha e assim como
você ajudar as pessoas só que de uma
forma diferente
vou ajudá las como eu tentando fazer
agora é abrir os olhos delas ensinando
que existe um outro mundo
além desses que a gente está vendo agora
como fernando falou agora que do iceberg
às vezes a gente só consegue ver as
coisas quando elas já estão aqui na
frente a gente não consegue ver quando
ela já tão atrás como os filhos as
crianças por exemplo eu com quatro anos
de a criação do chef de cozinha já
gostava muito de cozinhar vendo minha
bisavó vendo minha mãe vendo chef de
cozinha cozinhando e chef de cozinha não
é complicado né
e sempre me espelhei neles pra que eu
pudesse fazer um grande trabalho e
inspirar pessoas como eles me inspiram
nisso com quatro anos eu falei pra minha
mãe você cozinha muito bom
ela me disse é você acha que é fácil né
cozinhar
então vai lá na cozinha faz melhor nisso
eu falei para ela tudo bem mas você só
vai fazer o café da manhã enquanto isso
porque você é muito pequeno só quatro
aninhos não dava pra fazer algo mais
elaborado
então às vezes a fazer um café da manhã
tipo pão francês com mostarda da coco e
chocolate
daí eu dava pra minha mãe ela comia e
fazia carotti mas às vezes eu sabia que
estava um pouco ruim 17 anos eu fiz meu
primeiro prato que foi o macarrão
simples mais pra mim foi o começo de
algo grande o começo de alguma coisa
digamos inspiradora
eu posso não ter uma história tão linda
como de muitos aqui mas acho que é uma
história que eu só começando
com 18 anos eu pedi pra minha mãe pra
sair da escola porque a escola realmente
não estava me ajudando o meu sonho
ela só estava ensinando coisas
completamente inúteis
algumas delas porque matemática
português geografia são importantes mas
aprender como você deve chamar um papa
governador um presidente acho que não
vai servir para muita coisa
um dia estava na escola e me deram uma
prova e disseram como você chamaria o
presidente como você chamaria o papa
vossa santidade né eu escrevi lá não
vírgula eu falaria você porque ninguém é
melhor que outra pessoa eu não sou
melhor que você
não sou melhor que você não sou melhor
que você independente por qualquer coisa
por classe social país cor ou vamos
dizer assim como nasce um exemplo bem
meio tosco assim e às vezes as pessoas
pensam que a vida é só isso
é só fazer o mesmo circo sempre de
estudar na primária fazer fundamental
ensino médio ebep uma faculdade mas
definitivamente não é isso
quantos anos fazem que alguém tenta
fazer diferença mas não consegue fazer
com que todo mundo entenda isso mas eu
posso dizer hoje que eu quero muito
fazer a diferença
só que eu sou uma das pessoas que têm
coragem de plantar a sementinha e gala
com várias pessoas que vão me ajudando
como amigos pais ou até pessoas que
ainda não conhece que vão gerar mais
parceiros nessa missão de dizer para as
pessoas parem parem com isso e sempre
achar que temos que ser alguma coisa
temos que acreditar em alguma coisa
temos que já saber o que vamos fazer
quando fomos adultos nem vamos viver
porque a gente sempre tem que aprender
todos os dias na escola por exemplo eu
duvido muito que uma criança que passa
vamos dizer assim os dez anos estudando
nos anos 1º 2º 3º até o primeiro do
colegião se lembra de tudo o que
aprendeu
errado às vezes quando eu sou quando eu
estudava
vamos dizer assim vou deixar o suspense
quando eu estudava e chegava em casa
minha mãe perguntava o que você aprendeu
hoje filho não era nada eu simplesmente
decorava simplesmente queria tirar dez
pra minha mãe fica feliz comigo então
nesses oito anos que eu pedi pra minha
mãe eu saí da escola é ela me disse tudo
bem a gente vai incentivar isso dá em
casa eu vou te ensinar coisas que
realmente vão valer e que realmente vão
te ajudar no teu sonho era salvar
crianças adultos e pessoas idosas já por
meio da alimentação saudável e meio de
comunicações grandes porque a gente não
pode mudar o mundo só falando pra alguém
assim como falando pra uma pessoa
nós precisamos de algo grande para
transmitir o que nós sentimos eu acho
que talvez nem seja foi uma coisa com
coisa aqui mas eu acho que você entender
um pouquinho
é nesse período de quando eu tinha 8
anos
eu disse para minha mãe que eu queria
criar um programa de televisão porque
porque eu realmente precisava transmitir
isso para as pessoas transmitir o que eu
sentia e transmitir o que eu queria e
transmitir o que seria uma coisa mais
não mais fácil mas mas melhor para o
corpo delas melhor pra alma delas melhor
para elas do que sempre fazer sempre a
mesma coisa
às vezes quando estava na escola me
perguntava por que que a gente tem que
aprender que pedro álvares cabral
descobriu o brasil sendo que na verdade
ele invadiu o brasil matou centenas
milhares de índios escravizou milhares
de negros e ainda assim a história tá
certa mas é mentira pedro álvarez não
descobriu o brasília voltou a falar mas
eu estava lá a gente quem te viu quem
estava lá desde o começo eram os índios
praticamente o tesouro do nosso país e
que está desaparecendo assim tão fácil
porque a ganância do homem
porque o que que vamos dizer assim o
homem mas quer ter sucesso é dinheiro é
chamar a atenção por assim dizer
esses dias eu vi um vídeo de uma empresa
retirando marvel seja cortando uma
árvore para colocar um banner de uma
criança abraçando uma árvore qual que é
a lógica disso porque vocês não deixam
as crianças serem abraçadas
é isso que eu pretendo dizer é
praticamente uma ilusão que a gente está
vivendo mais ou menos porque a gente tem
que fazer parte de um mundo ou seja do
sistema porque a gente não pode criar o
nosso um porque a gente não pode ser o
que a gente quer
como segunda e depois ver o que vamos
fazer depois vou ver como nos sentimos
é você bem claro agora eu é fazer uma
palestra com o nome com o powerpoint mas
eu decidi improvisar porque eu não
conseguia memorizar toda a palestra
então eu decidir falar o que eu
realmente sinto agora que é isso
eu queria que vocês internalizar se um
pouco isso e pensar se a respeito de que
eu acho que mais do que ser alguém na
vida porque nós somos nós
eu sou eu você vocês já são josé
nós já somos alguma coisa senão nós
mesmos
talvez todos os dias nós façamos a
diferença às vezes outra algumas
palavras em espanhol é não dizer fazemos
a diferença dando um prato de comida
para algum morador de rua ou ajudando
uma velhinha atravessar a rua e isso é
diferença
isso é
saí da caixinha por assim dizer
eu acho que as pessoas ainda os adultos
as mulheres também todo mundo
as pessoas ainda têm muito que aprender
e eu também sobre sobre fazer diferente
sobre realmente ensinar alguma coisa e
aprender alguma coisa porque vamos
pensar de uma forma quando nós morrer
nos talvez a única coisa que vamos levar
daquela vida vai ser o nosso nome e
todas as lembranças todos os momentos
que nós vivemos nós vamos levar por
exemplo um iphone
nós não vamos levar por exemplo o nosso
carro ou roupas de marca ou nada disso
vamos levar nossas experiências de vida
vamos levar o que nós aprendemos e o que
nós ensinamos para talvez nossas
próximas gerações
oprah velha geração então eu não sei
mais ou menos quanto ao tempo agora eu
tentei dar uma improvisada porque eu
realmente queria falar disso
talvez algum de vocês tenham entendido
outras não mas a diferença talvez por
isso que o nosso título de cidade é
somos todos diferentes e eu digo que na
verdade somos todos iguais mas que nós
fazemos coisas diferentes
nós tentamos fazer a diferença quando a
palavra muitas vezes é então é
basicamente essa mensagem que eu queria
deixar na verdade dos pais para que eles
acreditassem nos seus filhos e não
subestimar assim a a inteligência deles
sobre o que eles podem fazer o que eles
podem ser
deixa eles viverem deixa eles
descobrirem que querem ser na vida
antes de mais nada então
eu acho que isso obrigado pela
oportunidade de estar aqui hoje e
i